اذا مشاهدينا كنا في متابعه هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي لمرشح الجوله الاولى للتحالف
الاجداد سنان اوغان والذي اعلن بشكل رسمي
دعمه للرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات حول هذا
الموضوع ايضا وهذا القرار تنضمرين مراسله
الجزيره فرح الزمان شوقي فرح الزمان ارحب
بك اذا قرار سنان اوغان بدعم رئيس التركي
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان ماذا في تفاصيل
هذا القرار وكان قد تحدث اوغان عن قرار
مبني على مصالح البلاد
قوى بالفعل كذلك
هو انكحدث انه ليس مفاجئا لا سيما انه
ياتي بعد عدد من اللقاءات بعد المباحثات
وبعد الحديث عن وضع شروط على الطاوله
اوغان تحدث صراحه عن عدم اعجابه باداء
المعارضه في الجوله الاولى تبنى خطابا
قوميا واضحا جعله وان جعله اقرب لليمين
لكنه جعله اقرب اليمين المتواجد في تحالف
الجمهور اي للمرشح رجب طيب اردوغان سنان
اوغان تحدث بشكل واضح عن ضروره دعم
الصناعات الدفاعيه عن ضروره مكافحه
الارهاب عن ضروره التواجد عدم تواجد من
يسمون او من يوصفون هنا
بالارهابيين في اي حكومه مقبله وفي كل هذا
اشارات لسياسه المعارضه ولمرشح تحالف
الشعب كمال كل جدار اوغلو يتحدث هنا ايضا
على ان الرئيس المقبل لتركيا عليه ان
يتوافق وان ينسجم مع البرلمان نحن نعلم ان
تحالف الجمهور على راسه حزب العداله والتن
الحليفه الحركه القوميه حقق معا اعلى نسبه
او او تجاوزا نسبه النصف في البرلمان
التركي وهو قصد بذلك انه يجب ان يكون
البرلمان في المرحله المقبله منسجما مع
السياسه الحكوميه وبالتالي مع رئيس البلاد
واشار بهذا ايضا الى دعمه اردوغان كذلك
يتحدث عن ضروره وحده تركيا ومستقبلها وما
الى ذلك بمعنى انه دعم الخطاب الذي يتحدث
عنه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
وينتقده منافسه كالجدار اوغلو لكنه هنا
ايضا خلال هذا المؤتمر الصحفي يتحدث عن
عدد من الشروط اول شرط من هذه الشروط هو
مساله اللاجئين نعلم ايضا ان اوغان المرشح
عن تحالف الاجداد الذي برز كم يميني متطرف
ان صح وصفه بهذا الامر شدد كثيرا على خطاب
ومساله اعاده اللاجئين وتحديدا يتحدثون عن
اللاجئين السوريين والافغان يشدد ايضا على
هذه المساله ويؤكد بان الرئيس القادم
وحكومتها عليها ان تركز على هذه النقطه
وفي اشاره لهذه النقطه تحديدا سفيان كان
حليفه رئيس حزب النصر اوميد اوزداغ قد
اجتمع في وقت سابق مع مساعد رئيس حزب
العداله والتنميه نعمان كرتون
على مساله اعاده اللاجئين كذلك يختلف
الطرفان حقيقه في كيفيه اعاده اللاجئين
على المستوى الزمني او على المدى الزمني
في اعاده اللاجئين قد يختلف الان في
المصطلحات ولكنهما يبدوان اكثر تقاربا في
هذه المرحله على هذه النقطه تحدث كورتول
مش في وقت سابق صباحا وهو ايضا ما اشر الى
امكانيه دعم اوغان لاردوغان في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات عن عوده عدد كبير
من اللاجئين السوريين وان وصف ذلك بانها
كانت عوده طوعيه وامنه ولذلك تركز الحكومه
التركيه الان على هذه المساله تحديدا
وتتحدث ايضا عن
مباحثات مع
النظام السوري يضمن تحقيق هذه النقطه التي
ركز عليها اوغان كثيرا هذا
ايضا اكد في البدايه او ركز كثيرا على
مساله وجود مرشح قومي يمثل التيار القومي
في تركيا وهو السبب الذي ادى لعدم انسحابه
في الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات حين يتحدث
عن هذا الامر في مؤتمر الصحفي بعد انتهاء
الجوله الاولى والتحضير للجوله الثانيه
فهذا يعني ان الرجل لن ينسلخ عن توجهه بل
انهم سيدعمه بشكل اكبر وسيطالب بالاهتمام
اكثر به التوجه القومي وهنا نؤشر ايضا الى
ان الحاليه الرئيس لحزب العداله والتنميه
والحركه القوميه وزعيمها دوله باتشي يتحدث
ايضا عن ان نسبه الخمسه في المئه سفيان
والتي حصل عليها في الجوله الاولى قد
يعتبرها البعض قليله لكنه يبرر هذا الامر
بانه استعد لهذه الانتخابات خلال فتره شهر
او اقل وهي فتره كافيه لكنه لو استعد اكثر
من لكان من الممكن ان يحصل على تسعه او
عشره بالمئه هذا يجرنا للسؤال الثاني هل
هذه النسبه حقيقه تستطيع ان تكون مؤثره في
صناديق الاقتراع تحديدا بعد هذا الاعلان
من جهته الذي تبنى خطابا شبابيان يمينيا
تحدث فيه عن ضروره حل مساله اللاجئين عن
ضروره عدم التعامل مع حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي او حتى الذي يوصف بالواجهه
السياسيه لحزب العمال الكردستاني والمصنف
هنا ارهابيا يبدو انه يركز تحديدا على هذه
المساله في هذه المرحله ونسبه 5% ان لم
تكن ستذهب كلها
للمرشح عن تحالف الجمهور اردوغان لكنها
بذات الوقت سيحصل على نسبه محدده من هذه
الخمسه بالمئه لماذا لان كل من دعموا
اوغان في مرحله ما قد لا يتطابق خطابهم
وارائهم مع تحالف الجمهور او مع توجهات
تحالف الجمهور لكن على الاقل هذا قد يوسع
الهوه او قد يوس ع الفارق بين الرجلين
بحسب بعض الخبراء هنا
شكرا لك يا فرح الزمان شوقي